welcome to this week's Android developer
office hours from Europe we are today in
campus London our startup building in
Slovenia so you can round about so
obviously we haven't had chance to
decorate yet but we are in the studio so
hopefully the video quality and the
sound quality is a little bit better and
we'll try and make it look a little bit
prettier over the coming weeks joining
me as always I'll be Matthew corns you
know Nick butcher not so lovely no you
in on a world will end vacation day
American the moon and welcome to people
have joined us in the hangar I'll be
looking down here quite a lot okay
unlock sony xperia hey andrew and hey al
what have you say hello make sure to
make sure that we can hear you hey guys
hey hey way to go i can just bring it up
the water ain't online little device
down here so the big news of the day of
course being the jelly bean statues back
on the north on the beginning you crazy
voluntary i need to go and see if you
are not government yeah dairy section
hands yeah pick up his holy single i
remember seeing that the day before I
okie pops is this kind of thing later
please lots of fun that's what I think
it is I have a few vents going on so
rich and I we're looking after their
visit Israel last week where we met up
with the local google developer group
tell they're very very actively with
Murphy and so we may not go how'd if you
talked about Android and Google Drive
was a hackathon ovation very great thing
I've ourselves on one and then here in
London this week and friday and saturday
in fact this will be another prevent
here in Google campus but I'm wondering
what has we hope you know that existed
is a sold out already
but we can go to meeting lots of play
and OFS see how that's the deficit kind
of slowly coming around as a net Enzo
given book tickets for this and nothing
in them than any other communities yeah
there's by 50 days for me across the
world over the next two months so look
out for those yeah we fertility
pathologies and 225 google tunes on the
ground I'm what I was going to say the
big use of course I yeah it wasn't the
jelly bean statue came back the big news
will adverse android hip hop affiliate
possibly recreations my demo today
announcing today you can tell remember
classes is that what being terrible
sound half opinion activation develop
devices which probably doesn't come much
of a shot Eric Schmidt maps those for
next limited still I wants to join us in
a hangar the boundary we've got Michael
had that myself Richard Thompson does
anyone from the Hangout have a question
before we give the moderator today I'm
just got a quick thing those guys who
are running a deficit in London have
released some standing room only tickets
so there are a few still remaining so if
people head to London up there fest calm
they may get to get tickets if they feel
like standing all day yeah yep i'll put
a link in the comments as well I look
there first info- I yeah all right we
were worried about this we didn't want
to live a lapel mics which the studio at
people party providers so if it's too
quiet we do have options so it might get
really loud now instead of being quite
quiet that's good with me so you can
moderate
hey Michael is that better is this thing
either time yeah we can hear you all
right I just put on the desk and then
every time I lean all the desk you get a
big knocking noise teething problems
never hello weirdest noises must be
coming through my dad's we can velcro
the microphones that we were told to
wear and we were like nah we don't need
those sorry this isn't entirely Android
focus we should have found some Android
microphones launch the trailer there we
go okay come on screw you guys ha
moderator doesn't come up in here every
day is anybody Michael yep Michael so so
much better thank you well thank you for
mentioning it because we'd have realized
on the YouTube video afterwards and had
said take it out in other news i'm new
google developers live video launched
yesterday so Roman Nurik and myself so
and started an Android design in action
show so where we were focusing on how to
how to implement under a design and we
did it in that form of a an apt makeover
we would take three of the applications
which the the app clinic look at on
every product and we applied the Android
design philosophy to them to kind of
like reskin and to conform with the
Android look and feel and so hokey that
was informative to a lot of people out
there to learn what you know how to
apply the hollow kind of design language
to your applications it was actually saw
it live on you guys are doing it it was
brilliant I mean you guys had the before
and after shots so you went through the
mistakes in the apps and then what was
good about the redesigned version I
found it really useful yeah I find that
format of the two side by side you know
really really helpful to kind of it
speaks volumes in a rather than reading
the documentation connected to the app
that's what that's what I do so I hope
you guys useful to you guys and
congressional Roman Erick Rowan did the
mock-ups last week so I do really master
he always does Romans intimate
so no does it say sit any live questions
or should we jump into the moderator
Andrew like the Android design video as
well excellent uh people shaking their
heads no so let's jump into the
moderator of which I have a copy online
exit seven mom yeah that's what the
little black window in the hangouts for
I need to show you things and say so
here well that right here okay re this
is from Phil H in the UK google play in
app purchases i want to be able to get
the prize for it in that purchase
product by the product ID when the app
starts from the billing info pages this
doesn't seem possible anyone nervous
possible so Phil unfortunately we don't
have an API for retrieving the prices
from the Play Store into application but
at the same time we recommend that you
show the prices in your application
because it reduces your cancellation
rate so the thing that you can do is of
sheet query your own server for those
prices and the the play store accepts a
CSV input file to import pricing
information so you can hold it all on
your server and export it as the CSV it
imported into the Play Store and your
server being single place that although
will you go down in bed thats NTSB into
out there's an asset and assets folder
but it does mean you're going to have to
update your application time to change
your price ago but yeah so we recommend
the the server based approach so you can
download the same CSV file but the play
team are indeed aware of the fact that
an API is very much desired and although
they're currently working very hard on
the new developer console they do have a
list of feedback from google i/o in
other places and that's definitely in it
so sorry that's not available quite yet
if at all next up i read that apps that
define uses feature Android hardware
camera in the manifest won't be
available on the Nexus 7 it only has a
front facing camera that's true however
my photo app should work on the nexus 7
using camera in 10 what to do so you can
specify requires users features camera
and then required equals false and then
it will play will work on the Nexus
tablet lapeer
play store and everything will go ahead
and work so I would recommend if you
want your app to show on the Nexus 7 so
that it uses the feature camera but it's
required ok so then Angie's got on to
see my question relates to the entry in
the manifest the nexus 7 users can
download the app that devices without a
camera ed google TV won't have the app
show up when they search and two yet in
terms of facing a mewling google TV you
have to actually disable touch screen
that family a clear fire way of
basically saying don't allow it on
google TV because obviously they're on
the touch screens so that'll be covered
really and I think it's something that
we've done to ensure that you really
have to actually say I'm going to
support google TV so that shouldn't be
an issue um yeah touch screen TVs yet
yet one day I was in them and
departments throughout the weekend and
there's a big demo TV and the guy was
trying to touch all the rounds for all
the different perhaps maybe think how
long until you do that together it's not
sure if you want that he thought i had
and print one of my TV anime they're so
used to that kind of stuff viewsonic
launched yesterday a TV which has
android on it which is a resistive
touchscreen it's about 27 inches only i
think it's around 27 I mean resistive
screen yeah let me dig out the the link
and i'll post out so you guys can that
drool over it yeah there are a couple of
manufactures it to pressure i would make
a cool I see what Andrew saying about
the is just posted in the chat as well
what about other devices that don't have
cameras I had this conversation with
another partner recently I couldn't
actually think of one between us we
never came up with another device that
doesn't have a camera at all um I think
if it happens in at the very very last
resort you could just bucket live either
place and could black list it make it
open to everything except Google TVs
Nexus Q
but again this speaks the whole android
approach sure it isn't it you should
rethink in concrete devices she's kind
of thinking capabilities and use this
pieces features to define the
capabilities you require those which you
don't require and then these packaged
manner to enable/disable Andrus has a
nexus q as well yeah I mean Nexus Q so
the Nexus Q again would not have a
touchscreen to this mom I bits not and
what happens if they plugged in a USB
camera and that was supported then what
happens right it's a funny one yeah does
the app have no functionality I'm
looking over here because Andrews over
here me it's does he have no
functionality that could be used could
you not import photos and use them in
your application my Instagram is still
very useful without cameras and they
look extra Andrews typing dis people
know we're not looking at the cameras
because we've got a screen that's just
slightly a off of the camera so whenever
anyone else talks we kind of have to
look a little bit away give you this
side of life we're just figuring out all
the kinks to the studio because the chat
window is 4 meters in front of us right
now so we can't actually read it unless
with a penny uh Andrew still typing ok
I'll get back to it as soon as he's
finished next month does that come from
it's it's the comedian youtube in joke
forgive me voting is closed thanks oh no
yep why would nexus 7 not support the
camera if it has a front one the app is
pretty useless on devices best camera
essentially it's a legacy thing that
Android the hardware the camera because
of the easiest feature faces an alias to
camera got rear facing so there is
another feature Android the hardware
camera up front facing so you can
specify them individually but if you
just use the camera version then that
implies rear facing camera which the
nexus 7 just now it's in the docs is in
the developer Docs when you look at the
uses feature and stuff but it's perhaps
not obvious at first documented yeah
just treated as rear camera
unfortunately ok anything I'd also say I
think we talked about this car lot in
his air talk this year Google i/o so
what is to talk titled retain my store
from the road
electrum for the logo yeah making good
apps great I think or electric boogaloo
I didn't techniques for handling this
kind of a feather yes sorry Android that
is you you understand the situation
that's exactly the situation right now
there isn't any magic way around it I
think you've got the the general gist of
it so is there any documentation I could
search for it on creating my own app
store I'd like to have an app store of
approved only apps for use in education
health care how this for now yeah I'm
sure the documentation would be hundreds
of pages and there's nothing definitive
there are various third-party companies
who quite happily provide branded app
stores or if you if want to do something
simple it's basically just a system that
can download a list of available apps
can check for updates and can download
those updates I'm happy to talk about it
offline but it's a lot of work for
something that may be a small project I
don't know how there was the concept and
app store before force a melon on
anything alternatively a much much much
much much much much much much easier
approach would be to launch an app into
the Play Store or however you wanted to
distribute it which just linked back to
apps in the Play Store so here's my list
of a product but then yes it's actually
download asleep Ximena Jason feed ya
patients its consumer feed then you get
for free all the update auto updating
functionality all the bandwidth costs
and all that already sorted out by us
and it has the benefit of you able to
then put that app yep in their place
till you can't list another store in the
place towards one there and guess the
rules please but that's how nvidia's
tegra zone works isn't it exactly yeah
TegraZone is a good example of what
exactly were talking about just link
straight back to us any comments on that
that was actually for Andrew Kelly again
listen here you should take a microphone
on Andrew come on and we've got another
one from educating its hold on he's just
laughing at us they're just jumping to
the Google+ comments jayco so if that's
not
on google+ man it's asking if anyone
knows how you get your how you can
replace the glass and the nexus 7 as a
friends dropped is on a concrete floor
in two hours applying it oh ouch I think
they're the official answer is go to
play that google com and buy another one
but I don't know of any way they can
replace it so if anyone knows anywhere
that can help dry out then please chime
in in the comments um I'm not aware yet
check your local search engine yeah I
don't know anything it's best for these
things I don't know if calling the
customer support they would allow fixing
of that at a paid at your expense i
don't know i think at the cost it might
actually work out that's just to buy
another one that's just really on his a
galaxy nexus of with massively smash
screen as well Alan's clear yeah
wandering around Berlin while it's
raining trying to find place you haven't
you don't know yeah that happens to do
like any she gets the next moderator I
just for Josh yes us guys are all on the
next 27 here at Point 2 307 long hang on
we all personalize it in different ways
I don't know why I'm at defiled his with
a cloud thing on the back foot there you
go but ABC News it was swag but that was
it sure work uh okay yep we're good
onward question is from andrew kelly
again yeah I know you don't comment on
future releases and products we didn't
sign up at the start of the show but
join these shows your uncle a few trees
40 maps or things that you don't really
know except the last one but is there
any chance that the android plug-in for
eclipse will eventually include
templates for things like
actionbarsherlock it would be a useful
feature that would help the doctor of
action bar nah and Al's very trying to
be commented saying the best place to
check is the google group the adt dev
google group if you suggest it there
then who knows what will happen yeah
unfortunately we can't comment on that
whether it's likely whether it's not
likely or anything okay yeah feeds bear
in mind is at Google i/o again and power
say that we're working on a Google
action bar compatibility library so as
and when that launches perhaps we'll see
that in some tending
if they're knowing if we analyzed it and
then hit it ah next question is from a
new person Andrew Kelly the one man
moderator machine Andrew Kelly is there
a nice weight but the good questions
from you they are these are a nice way
to clear the metadata of a nap EG price
we've already answered this one earlier
in the talk today that isn't a nice way
no we don't have a bug it has no
official API is the official answer no
wasn't it the only answer a nice way he
says in the rest of the question i'm
currently scraping screen scraping the
google play website I'm not doing it
often or in a spider-like fashion in a
bed net exactly there is a bunch of
people who reverse engineered their
protos offers that market uses and
lizard right very is Association yeah
API but I'm it's not official is still
exchange you may break anytime so you
know at your own risk or I won't panic
I've defined it's from andrew kelly the
next question I've defined a theme for
my app and have styled things like
buttons etc but the buttons using my
dialogues don't seem to pick up the
styling is there a specific base style I
need to extend for dialogue I can't
remember off hand probably probably oh
yeah I think dialogues come under their
own like an im- aces of the field doing
i always do is I just kind of fire up
and in sight smell and the stars like
XML ship with the SDK and the platform's
raise all that good stuff and search
through it for likely candidates up how
i always find my bright stars to take
them never end but not off the top my
attorney andrew canty can turn his
microphone on because his missus is
watching The X Factor dual-purpose
living room one person on X Factor one
on Android developer office hours we
could talk about X Factor would that be
more intriguing to the general
population I'd love to watch it but
surely not only 3 g's in Android n no
rights see half a billion devices
activated so back
at the top of the which we ask is there
any questions from inside the Hangout
yet because we're munching through the
moderator is a double coming in on the
and you the best schedule up though so
Josh it was asking for using nexus
heavens Chinese back in big wants to buy
a nexus 7 he's a budding developer
currently in school studying mobile dare
anyone sees it for testing and playing
out and there's no question but yeah I
recommend it it's a good device it's a
Nexus device without any carriers in
between you and google so it's kind of
going to get past updates and so on and
so as a developer you could do a lot
worse and it's also pretty reasonable so
heartily recommend it that one delicious
there's another one of the bottom of the
cheapest road shalise broadcast receiver
and service to get update from a server
updates not scheduled it's random thank
you sounds to me like a perfect case for
push messaging using GCM Google Cloud
messaging tossed order so that does
require you to have some kind of server
infrastructure of your own so you have
to use your server infrastructure to
ping our / servers which will then send
a tipple down to the device and so that
is one pilots you could set up an appt
in Europe for example to do that if
that's not possible then yes you could
use the alarm manager to schedule
schedule to wake up and start a service
to to grab will check for updates
essentially but my gut feeling is trying
to go for push for this kind of non
scheduled thing is you'll be much much
more backward flattery family and also
the updates will come through faster you
know in straight away I'll be pushed
down to your device rather than know
some period delay yeah please don't make
a polling service at least that would be
pretty around this I guess and if you do
use the inexact repeating alarms because
there that lets do android phase shift
your alarms to try and line them all up
so you're not waking up the device the
whole time I'd be bad if you don't do
that then you can start occurring in
battery status as a battery hog and then
people will install your app and
new in public yeah let's just boom what
is from Ferris the recommended way to
control sequel aight database connection
in a multi-threaded environment is
having one instance of database helpers
share between threads a good idea and
does using a content provider help yes
using a content provider is the
recommended way to control a super light
database can really hit inside Android
it's just going to provide the
functionality and synchronization that
you need without you having to code it
all up yourself I would personally go
for a Content writer in this situation I
know other dads that have gone for
Singleton's and you know trying to
synchronize it themselves or things like
that passing curses around but I mean
content providers the thing that Android
provides to do it so unless you're
pretty confident about coding it up
yourself at you might as well take the
content right now there's loads of good
sample code for content providers out
there yet the less and a multithreading
synchronization code you by yourself the
better just for debugging and mixes it I
dude I'm just scrolling down to a
college again so worried me in there
jeepers comics asks is there way to get
a list of accounts without going through
the accountant I Jeff select Olivo
contacts contacts contract lot settings
always return 0 anything like this oh I
haven't thought about the contacts
contract on settings I'm not quite sure
where it is because I've always just use
a calendar to get list of the accounts
on the device me too and why would you
want to avoid that are you trying to not
have to ask for the permission I guess
but then you're still doing the thing
that the permission why would you try
and get around the permission and then
still in the sound slinky yeah we feel
like account managers the right way to
do this yeah complex contract yeah it's
possible that that settings is returning
zero because you don't have the account
manager Commission as well other things
outside of it might be using the account
manager to get those things you should
just check in the API dr. see if it does
require those permissions it would be
strange if we did have a way of getting
around the account manager permission
and we've probably try and close it if
there was awake yeah that's house again
yeah it's good
yeah okay in which case we are I can
refresh this sometimes they come in to
really join the governess away there's a
question in and Google+ stream again you
by FIBA I did it this way to draw charts
on Android anyone but me you recommended
charting libraries I don't know there's
a chart in Jupiter before I drew my own
once did she pixel the lines and stuff I
did a lot of canvas well good good
canvas yes yeah I ended up for just
trying to make a bar chart which was
just fairly generic and just tried to
stick to a bit of an adapter pattern so
I wasn't constantly going in adding in
pixels left right center it's not too
bad to do on your own make me it'd be
nicer though sister likely to do it for
you but I can't say I found any and
think some people yeah a charge one day
they'll use any pounds on counseling a
few count graciela ha she did you to
graph and I be a country which one I'm
gonna run it to the Android UI review
examines every few interesting ones
chart droid Android plot an HR engine so
I can't recommend in the myself for
anyone libor in the comments wants to
comment on their experience using any of
these starting engines and that's like
it wasn't interesting one I've ever
seeing github open-source not they get
her back there they have a analytics
package ping they open source that app
and that had some pretty graphs in it Oh
might be worth checking up I don't know
what they did but it looked a very
attractive attractive always better we
strive for attractive obviously we don't
so someone else has join us in the
Hangout Scott hey Scott help do you have
any questions for us today in the
Hangout but no just listening in and
thank you though thanks for joining
looks like you got quite a tech desk set
up over there that's not what my called
it yeah I bet it looks fun for you do
nice John Scott I'm sorry kagan where
are you joining us from
South Florida nice what time is it just
86 early am it's not so bad excellent
well welcome you if you do have any
questions feel free to jump in because
we're out just posted stucco fooling
took every charting librarian has tons
here android charts graphs diagrams of
plots chopping this is one sack
over play so quick Google and yeah
you'll be so late graphing packages yeah
tons I guess Bieber was actually looking
for a recommendation from us then he's
already found that you know there's
hundreds of these things which one
should i use it looks like some ain't up
arms is listed it down to three which is
chart droid android cloth and HR indian
normally nitin so some of the others
have a commercial license as well so it
could rule now hello try and make money
the most expensive all was is it all of
three hundred dollars so why am I always
like running my aim so he's unconscious
yeah how I roll out of context and I
clip that check the video I always like
robbing my own it's nothing like a chunk
of canvas could also be late I could
check the cameras were such yeah Jesus
red so why Christo asks why android
doesn't have multiple users and so
anyone who buys Android blobs might
realize that there's some underpinnings
of that coming already open source thing
jellybean so watch this space to see how
they get exposed yeah I've seen people
from Android user groups around the
world typing commands into terminals and
Android devices and magic things
happening so it's all rumors but and
next that and more it's very fun which
Pennsylvanian asks is it possible to buy
cards into google now as an app
developer also no unfortunately there is
no developer API and given up as is and
then maybe it'll get you here right now
so you're interesting well yeah that
would be fun interesting to hear what
kind of information you'd like to serve
isn't there yeah if all we do you just
want to override I have a different
weather car for a different source
regular what I want then you're prettier
as some of the actions you can form from
the cards to just fire off intense which
you can you know provide alternative and
you have a stock ticker and Omega yeah
and go we're just gonna pour of your
apps onto that countdown up in there oh
that reminds me I still have to
implement um rich notification on
chronometer Ultimates don't watch for it
gets reviewed on the app with you all
Friday used to be maybe I should do that
now so they don't want to do some live
coding very it's quite easy on my own
paws are just have set the chronometer
rich notification up and on that as you
can kill it again John elected guys know
what app review it's gonna be rich I
know well thank you for submitting it
out that's my pleasure oh I'll be for
everybody so the American side of our
team are reviewing timer and countdown
acts on Friday and our knows that I made
one about 50,000 years ago when I first
died Android so we put it up for review
so my teams could have ripped me a part
or annual or something on friday which
is nice well they make of that you are
not awesome they might and if they do it
all be down to my research Rice's much
better designs than mine even though
apparently I didn't implement them
properly still try to distance herself
somewhat from me up okay was kind of
like my designs are you tense yeah do
you need a viewpager between camp
balance not much you I'll do that as
well I'll put a viewpager a little put a
deep I didn't exist back then swiping
didn't just gestures yes just yeah we've
all watched that video okay why we're
kind of filling in time here cuz we got
half an hour to go my new participant
was jump on him uh it says his name is
Abby i beez got pitre doesn't have a
video maybe he has a microphone hey Dad
you have a question for us
i wiii exhaustedly him imagine if it
wasn't for andrew kelly this hangout
would have been four minutes but
fortunately hundred can be bought all
the questions ever sources at the top
here still seven questions mean seven
people interested enough I'm gonna pick
on the live participants a a couple of
you said you tuned into the Android
design in action session yes any any
feedback anything you liked or you might
see more of you spent too long useful
and anything that we used about oh one
of the things that could be cool would
be if you could get the developers to
join in as well and and see whether
there's some thinking behind their
designs or how sort of they could
implement them because it's quite
causing the design changes but hearing
about how to actually implement as well
could be useful to that I think there's
something the guys in the US dude only I
think they've had a couple of our view
so they actually have the guys who
developed it on the Hangout live in it
yeah you right it does add another level
kind of understanding and not yet they
got tips and tricks and great way to
learn and I understand mix you're
limited to about half an hour so what
you can do is really limited in it it's
kind of a weighing out between whether
it's worth getting more a pre-designed
in or whether it's worth focusing on a
few twice video we can make it longer if
you think a longer format would be
woodworking could make it an hour like
this and it's quite a lot of work to do
the app redesigns I said try and turn
around three of days a week Tech Tech's
take polaroids fine and all Romans work
from instantly I'd screwed up so we're
working about diversifying it into a bit
more of the general show as well so
having more talking about more in the
new so we spend a little bit talking
about the hollow colors generator which
lets you generate the themes and buttons
and xml files to personalize the
philippine so do more of that kind of
news and maybe and they talking about
what's going on in the community not
just being at a pre design so trying to
persuade out a little bit without you
know spending full time job redesigning
out be quite cool hasn't didn't write i
produce a video or
this week in Android or something like
that that was he did and I'll five
minutes spot on what's coming up this
week which were halfway through it out
yep that was it was also pretty useful
because there were some of the things
that were going on the I wasn't aware or
say we've got some upcoming other ways
of discovering our videos soon as well
and keeping up to date with everything
that's going on on this pretty much now
constant TV channel if you go to
developers.google.com/live products the
calendar is almost full soon there be
more than one show on its immediate
Wednesday stretcher the whole day you
can watch something from the Google team
live on YouTube live and die my
resistance you guys to needs and
multiple officers lectures you tune into
the u.s. one as well I've picked up the
asia-pacific one before knacks it's sort
of seven o'clock in the morning and
watched it during breakfast so sad I am
really gonna watch that one as well
they've done a slightly different format
they do less questions and they're doing
a bit more news about the week and then
they do a technical spot as well so it
is worth watching them what do you think
of that format hell I quite like it i
like the the technical presentation of
the start it'll be interesting to see
how many different topics they can cover
and whether they go into depth or
whether they keep stuff quite light but
i think it what seems to work quite well
and it means that they don't don't end
up with half an hour to fill at the end
or anything like that so i should write
and so yeah I've got some more questions
fish especially being on the deepest
blue you're gonna and yes a David Scott
with in-app billing is there a way to
power some kind of string like a better
for payload let me show up on Google
Checkout / pay up or no sorry it's quite
similar to the other question really
isn't it trying to find out the prices
maybe even though but ya know everyone
is from Chris tovar here my html5 css3
so outrageously bad on Android I mobile
devices in general even in batteries may
pull at one coracoid device is the html5
experience really slow petrified cover
success especially with chrome OS should
not get more attention
I'd be kind of interested to know
whether you referring to like the
embeddable webview whether your phone
into actual google chrome because those
are very different though yep chrome
team they kind of energy focusing on the
html5 spec another sporting speed etc
and they live down yet look if you're
watching frisco oh is andrews why sorry
I'm gonna meet you Andrew it is a busy
day unless you want to know if you want
to say something before you get meted no
answer oh sorry you've been much as the
x factor was good i think we can only
listen to five seconds of anything
without having copywriters popping back
to the html5 thing is probably also
worth thinking about the processing
power in mobile devices a lot of
websites i see and they start getting
into really complex staff are really
designed for desktop so trying to run
them on a mobile processor is it's just
painful it's it's akin to trying to run
flash on a mobile processor yeah a nice
good point even quad core mobile devices
if you compare that to a quad-core
desktop that performance it's different
is still metod yeah it's at layers upon
layers upon layers of abstract ations at
knitting out when you have these
resource constrained devices the closer
you get like down the stack bit more
performance you're going to get so as
you add more more layers like a web
layer on top NSN your name Thank it was
yeah its benefits of WebGL do similar
trend a big developers moving away from
like Facebook the end of myself this one
with marks at the post comments today
and I saw a six-under kinder and make is
a wonder list I got away from edge
tomorrow they would attain IAM and have
gone native no and yeah yeah go six
Wunderkinder better performance still
looks like an iOS app but did they say
they've launched already or is it I'm
sneaky did they say nice to ready yes
does it ever Google tas thinking I
haven't hmm i shall check it get back to
them on whether that app does what I
rested or not it's quite interesting
that yesterday at TechCrunch conference
that marks are having actually said
they'd ship moving to html5 was probably
one of the worst mistakes he's made on
mobile so
that we've wasted two years of
everyone's time or something yeah the
interesting to see what the native app
which he's announced will come out does
does look like and how fast and super
snappy it is they've already got to put
a lot of effort into making it amazing
mail there's a lot of anticipation and
regenerative acquired like what
instagram the lightbox yes both and
they're still in hiring more people as
well so were their building and building
building that team talking about hiring
more people so what advertising spot
here aight aight our team our time our
team is currently looking for one new
member to sit here in the London office
so if you're into Android and fancy
developer advocacy off Android get in
touch with me on Google+ i'm really
looking for someone with some european
language skills but there you go get in
touch to me on google+ and we can have a
talk about it ok we can fill the spot
soon before with its head champion head
carrot comes and goes like anything at
Google um any more free more or joining
there's another one from davis cup okay
um so this was still the google play
getting a payload in the report and what
we should what would you suggest the
best solution for an apple opossum with
possibly 40,000 separate in-app payments
with hundreds added monthly what would
you suggest is the best solution for a
nap with 40,000 separate cadet payments
so no daily was a magazine a pansy had
one single application which can
download multiple magazines and issues
they're all so not okay okay well
definitely the eye dr who knows if
anyone's tested the csv import and
export with 40,000 items in it but
that's going to be the way to go that's
nothing to try and work out sales of
individual well i have to design the
apple no no in reporting on it basically
taylor csv phones oh there's a little
bit more useful that then tears i
imagine um I no idea goofy about they
will pass it on to the TV build it yeah
I don't know what in your sales report
what comes out for not betting items of
each one is a separate they must be
separated sure
we see the way you can spit it on the
sales important hopefully you'll see
what items purchased I don't have an
appt with in-app billing in it that's
live but people by sniffing does anyone
on the Hangout have an in-app billing
app currently live in the Play Store no
interesting I'm just go Mia cassandra is
typing again there's been quite a few
things going through the chat scott says
GameSalad and addresses is working one I
don't know why gamesalad came up did I
miss something no methods need GameSalad
yes at building up Scott's talking in
code that sounds like the older writer
titanium or no the Android developer
labs thing I think it went off to MIT
yeah and right at the loading a center
that Umberto GameSalad seems to be a
cross-platform application for
generating apps Oh a then says now I've
got your attention how about how about
integrating voice over IP video calls
voice over IP video calls with hangouts
via android to the audit dine-in invite
people who aren't on google plus
hangouts maybe is their intent
assignment that'd be very cool how about
it voice over IP video calls with
hangouts fire Android integrating the
two you talking about like I just
kicking off a set hang out so it just
passes off to the Google+ app to start
it are you talking about having it run
of our infrastructure and then give you
a stream of audio and video to show your
app i'ii be playing a game and can type
in audio and video whatever just it just
seems that it's a similar technology and
you know we've had we've had the
discussions of it of how to take say
we've got a video a VoIP call
platform how to enjoy the versatility of
hangouts within then you know or vice
versa making a call if you will by way
of the google hangout to somebody okay
this one's gonna come on a second i
think it's probably uh sorry Bella we
just dropped out on the main I think
Julia here I you just be coming back on
in a second I think what Scott's after
you talking about on forensic people in
directly into a hangout so basically
you'll be able to select a group of
people that you want to join a hangout
and they get invited in essentially you
know I sure you know cuz one to go at
one level absolutely so we missed quite
a bit of that unfortunately due to the
dropper dropout sorry so I'm still
somewhat confusing you trying to get a
voice over IP protocol right step or
something to connect to hang out or do
you just that you mean use hangouts
within your own app
and as I'll suggested even creating a
conference from within a hangout to back
out to a video call over VoIP the
technology seems seems similar it would
just be interesting to enjoy to use both
directions yeah both hang out from your
educational yeah the hangouts that on
Google+ team do yeah they sending you
know we'll talk about the hangouts API
and what you can and can't deal with in
that I don't know about you know
connections to other you know video
audio in stream but they would be advice
once that I reckon yeah I think it'd be
interesting to know whether you could
access that to the Hangout API so not
prada um I don't think we give anyone
access to the audio video screens yeah
but it's also but it's a google plus
cool okay let's have one more quick run
through the moderator and the comments
just in case anything's come in I teen
vote seven questions next following the
comments right nothing you're coming in
yeah please come in and said thanks for
the link to charting libraries know
anyone either and information so don't
you dare is 11 can I think obviously
battery stuff what is accessible through
right here bloop ipad is nakul show
moments of my clients then often that's
why she did maybe it rolls its own but
might be worth and technical source code
for that yeah yeah they're quite pretty
little brush what look I'd say you know
the third party libraries a great and I
would invest using and fast they don't
do what you do tweak them change them
fix them up and stuff and then recommit
it back the community always another bus
so phil has just handed in the gfs
comments asking if the the voting blocs
section of the design site which goes
through all the different controls you
can use within the application and
whether it's gonna get em examples
include at some point so I guess I
follow up do you mean like visual
examples which I think it already has
are you more talking about code examples
if it's the latter I'm gonna go ahead
and say maybe not up in the design site
is very much just that I would say if
you feel like the kind of the technical
documentation side which just goes to
the code that you will need and all the
API demos and so on we should ship with
SDK or the documentation on in the
reference section or even the end of
training pages if you feel like they're
not you know up to snuff I'll be
interesting maybe we could do a better
job of join them up you know linking
through from from say they're the
building blocks page 2 now here's how to
influence it then that would be worth
looking at and the documentation the
design documentation is also part of the
android open source project so people
can actually submit their own changes if
they want to located in the frameworks
base docs package so anyone wants to
make fixes they can fix it semitic to
garrett and become a famous author of
the design documents mm-hmm as you
advised your hiney see just in there yep
yes I felt terrifies he means their code
examples yes sir I think the desire is
to keep the design section down to the
design so it's not to scare off designer
swift code and but yeah certainly
linking through two tips for
implementation is interesting coming out
and turning I think it's it's nice to
see that androids got to a point where
of the designers is so important
compared to back in the day when we
didn't have such kind of strict standard
so I think keeping the two separate has
kind of made a lot of sense but yeah
maybe it's a case in easley a couple of
strings time together nicely I really
like the redesign of the end for sites
you have a you know design divert
distribute free pillars and Android app
and they kind of separated out but maybe
we do need to
think through a certain logical places
yeah the dispute one's got some great
information on publishing and getting
your play page together I've been quite
a lot of people to the distribute book
originally appointed every with the
design page but now you distribute links
as well as I've become more familiar
with different deep links inside that
that's what the device large energy
mechanisms yes device our generator uh
Steven brothers just joined us in the
chat and in the Hangout just one if he's
got any questions before we sign off
today and vivi says it moderate Islam
the moderator is indeed locked I saw
that as well I don't know mega saw has
to unlock it would have liked us but I
don't yeah I think didn't party so that
you get to a point where it it lock it a
bit before so then people can get food
and down huh I think you mentioned they
said get your questions at early next
week cuz I'm gonna lock it before the
event cuz they were all coming in during
unit must be yeah I don't know how to
unlock it again no Sparky has the power
very weak I preferred it with the
questions coming enjoying the thing so
next week we won't lock it I have a
Phillies not a condom on an automated
trigger because he's already got the one
for next the office of the moderation
for next week open it says come back at
six o'clock to submit your questions
okay also we actually got sort of the
time roasters yeah a time you can't post
any questions and is it when I'm I call
you but just wondering as ice question
sorry okay all right does anyone know
whether the Android and proximity alert
on the location manager is battery
intensive is the ad proximity alert on
location manager battery intensive no no
and this is a pencil stuff I just used
the pacification yeah I supposed to reto
a very very long time about this he said
that even though the GPS icon is there
he said that it is actually designed to
be quite efficient in terms of not
actually even GPS chip until it actually
needs to he told me to look in the
source code to see if I could then stop
it from doing that and then essentially
you brought my own version of it when I
was looking into it a little while ago
but at the same
I think some people have commented that
it may not be the case so I'd say I'd
still retos so reto says here yes this
will definitely eat your battery okay so
ignore I said you never want to be
setting more than a couple of proximity
alerts in any case the use case you
described isn't really cater for
proximity alert I basically want to add
about 20 sometimes 80 alerts with no
time expiration with a radius of around
500 meters okay a better alternative
would be to use an alarm and a service
to check your current location against
your set of annotations this will let
you manage the location to show you want
to use GPS or cell ID as well as the
frequency of checks doing it this way
will let you manage your battery much
more effectively so yeah Britta cystic
well and retos the man on batteries and
ease nephew he's battery power go read I
hope you not to me that if you are then
you can get me back hey Steven you got a
question that you have a question
regarding Whitlock's okay understand me
I have a and service which ranked in the
back crown which collects the location
data and do some company Oh necessary to
register a clock when screen is off so
we have lost you three half of that
horribly ok so r evans yeah I haven't
service which is registering in wait
clock and dust collector location data
always when this trees off and do you
need we need an way clock for this when
screen is off to get enough computation
power to do some filtering of the GPS
positions on the one or is it just
sufficient to do it without the wake up
yeah
yeah he will get course pretty quickly
afterwards so it depends I don't know
how all the computations are going to
take but if it's more than a second or
two then yeah definitely go for wait
look look it is it's a good choice to
learn to read okay yeah just take the
weight lock and then turn it back off
and get a little drop it as soon as you
can another question on Josie's turned
up hey y'all see finally you turn off
right at the end of it he's got these
lower third sort of that paki as well
sorry we couldn't be an Israel with you
this week I'm sure your web as much
better than ours apparently we've got
another question come true and yet from
Benjamin vice oh then I'm oh so much him
a shout have been and be because they
took care of me while I was able to snap
in Berlin last week and take your advice
and all those other guys Absalom thank
guys you they got some evil so yeah ben
says other any intentions on sporting
Grable as an official android
application I don't know what Gradle is
and we can't talk about some platforms
and now you might be a bit more today
this has been some talk on the on the
google groups as net forums a band well
I think initiative started by call to
arms by Jake Wharton yeah that's right
and basically they decided to take a
step back and start from scratch on the
Android building system see what's
happening Gradle is one of the systems
that was in there as a potential for
support it seems to be less favored
because it's not a mainstream system by
mainstream I just mean it's got a
critical mass of users I'm sure there
are not people who really like it I
can't see it from what's being said at
the moment being supported in the first
part of the new build system but there's
nothing to say that it wouldn't have
support for a built later because there
are quite a few people who are
interested in seeing it if if Benjamin's
really interested adt bash dev is the
group on Google Groups jump in and
the soup it can be adapted to what you
need and see if the guys are willing to
put in the effort to produce what you
want cool cars the nothing cool thanks
all right well now that your C's got
here it's time to go give you a chance
here you can take over um thanks all for
joining us again today from our first
hangout from the new studio over at
campus London hopefully we'll get to
interview some of the local startups
around here on air sometime soon as well
I got an amazing you coming to Denver
London again yeah that will be in this
building 2 over the look thank you very
much until next week keep following this
questions into the moderator for next
week and do give us a feedback on the
Android design in action show thanks for
guys cheers everyone and stop the broad
elegant